las protestas buscan que con este nuevo
censo se haga una redistribución de
recursos del estado más acorde a la
población actual de las regiones Por qué
insiste Entonces el gobierno en retrasar
la medida
bueno el gobierno es que hay problemas
técnicos que hay imposibilidades
técnicos para llevar a cabo el
censo del 2020 es decir ahora se tiene
que llevar el 2022 después se postergó
al 2023 y ahora postergado el 2024 por
supuestas motivos técnicos No pero en
realidad es es un tema absolutamente
político No porque no solamente
repartición de de presupuesto Santa Cruz
es unos departamentos que más ha crecido
pero Hay ciertos departamentos que han
crecido y otros que han de crecido
Entonces sí va a afectar económicamente
muy muy fuertemente a ciertos sectores
sobre todo Rurales pero es un tema
político vinculado a los conflictos que
tuvimos en octubre del 2019 no hay
varios intereses que se están jugando y
bueno la posterización del censo la
pelea
posteriales en eso tiene que ver con
este tema sobre todo político no
intereses del gobierno Que bueno que
está en contra de los intereses que
pueden haber en otros lugares de la
oposición en general y bueno
vinculado a los conflictos que hubieron
el 2019 pero este domingo el propio
expresidente Evo Morales ha criticado al
gobierno de su propio partido no es un
secreto que hay una lucha interna entre
ambos dirigentes se puede quedar solo
Luis Arce en su empeño de llevar el
censado 2024
Por eso yo creo que es su posición así
simple sin retroceder en llevar el censo
al 2024 Porque si el octubre del 2019
nos dejó en cierto sentido bien
polarizados porque hay había una
polarización muy fuerte ahora hay una
fragmentación y la posición de Morales
entra dentro de estas de esta
fragmentación
de los ciudadanos bolivianos en general
Porque si usted se da cuenta lo que han
hecho con todo desde octubre del 2019
han desplazado el conflicto que antes
podía ser sociedad civil sociedad
política a la sociedad civil nos estamos
enfrentando entre nosotros no hay una
violencia muy grande y eso no se puede
ver en estos 21 días de paro y en
diferentes lugares y regiones del país
de enfrentamiento entre diferentes
grupos no solamente del más contra la
oposición o contra los ocho ciudadanos
porque no hay una oposición como tal
sino del más entre sí no
conflictos violentos Donde ha vuelto a
surgir el estribillo que marcó los los
conflictos del 2019 de guerra civil aura
no es decir incluso hay esas posiciones
recalcitrantes Entonces estamos en un
momento en que la misma sociedad civil
la misma sociedad por los ciudadanos
estamos absolutamente divididos Y eso se
ve no son los discursos si no se ve en
la cotidianidad todos los días estamos
enfrentados entre nosotros no